my brothers and I made a lot of bonfires  growing up and so we wanted to replicate  so we partnered with a little of candle  fish one of the things I love about  working with you guys was that it was  such a personalized process that I could  dump in here with an idea and actually  speak to the person who has the  knowledge and I think that created a  better end result I could come to you  and say hey we kind of want this woodsy  vibe we want to can't fire vibe and you  can point me in the right direction as  far as the set goes and then we came for  this idea of the wood wig and the  crackling of the week that reminded us  of the Firestone  some of the best conversations I've ever  had or around the fire and when you look  into the fire kind of slows you down a  little bit helps you think and how it  draws out just a really good  conversation and it brings about a sense  of community  Oh